i'm disappointed in hollywood i think
there's a
safety factor a lazy factor that's come
in i'm not gonna lie i don't disagree
with what you're saying and what people
are saying
shane we're hoping to get your take on
what might be the problem with hollywood
movies today i i don't know if there's a
what is the problem i think there's a
lot of disgruntled unemployed people
bitching about what's being made because
they're not working
i mean and that's that's part of why i
did what i did i got tired of not
working so went out and created content
i'm not knocking anybody who's not
working um
i
i think the big complaint from everybody
is well it's all sequel prequel and
remake and it's all you know spandex you
know men in capes and spandex and action
hero movies and
if that's what they're considering the
problem but there's still plenty of
content
um
i i learned from a studio head about
nine years ago when when these superhero
movies were really becoming a thing
and and they told me you ain't seen
nothing yet it's going to get
unbelievable with with different studios
buying you know acquiring different
branches of different comic book
companies whether it's dc or marvel or
different you know one-offs
in in like remaking movies that we've
all heard of and i asked why why do you
do it so well there's a big audience for
it and i get that
but
they said the the branding's already
there you know when a studio makes a
movie people forget that there is a
tremendous amount of pna that goes into
it you know princeton advertising and
pushing this thing and when you have a
project i mean you can take something
like jungle cruise i mean you've got you
know two of the biggest stars in the
world in it
everybody knows what it is disney's
jungle cruise you know i mean 140 000
people go to disneyland every day when
there's no pandemic so everybody should
know that that's built in branding you
know it's it's about for studios it's
it's you talk about mitigating the risk
you talk about lessening the chances of
putting all this money into television
commercials and billboards that are
going to get covered by another film
next week and
pushed aside
and people
people already have a knowledge of you
know
what it is because we've seen it as you
know fantasy island adam's new tv show
that's been remade and is now on fox we
all know what fantasy island is that's
built in branding you know they did it
with dynasty they did it with dallas
you know they reboot everything now
it
i don't think it's as much about there
aren't any new ideas i think it goes
back to fear i i honestly think it goes
back to fear with decision makers
wanting to make shows that were proven
successful at one time or had built
built-in branding that people are going
to want to watch for curiosity factor
they're going to want to watch because
they loved it at one time i'll tell you
a show that would
blow it out right now that would do
really well they would just remake heart
to heart can you imagine that show today
that's a modern day mr mrs smith yeah
you know that show would be a great
remake
um
i i it's just one of those things though
i mean i i think the
the remakes have become a bit much for
me
art's nothing but opinion there is a
hungry audience out there for content
um
i i don't want to say anything's wrong
with hollywood but i think a lot of
of
disgruntled people in town that have
fresh ideas that they believe their
scripts are really different and good
and they probably are
are upset when they see airspace and
screens filled with remakes that were
done 20 30 years ago that's where the
frustration comes from and again i'm not
knocking people that
are
not working i mean again i i got tired
of watching sequels prequels and remakes
get made and finally just said screw it
i'm just going to find a way to make my
own stuff because nobody else wants to
maybe my stuff is that bad but
that's that's why i try to push people
to really find ways to partner with
people that can get their stuff done god
forbid somebody loves your little indie
project and says you should be directing
the next superman i mean it could happen
you know and uh
i i i i'm disappointed in hollywood i i
think there's a
safety factor a lazy factor that's come
in i'm not gonna lie i don't disagree
with what you're saying and what people
are saying
but
you know the opportunity to
to get a studio or a platform such as a
netflix to commit if you have an
original series idea it's going to cost
them between 50 and 150 million dollars
for 10 hours of content that's a big
risk
on something that hasn't been proven
when everybody's afraid to make a chance
and you know when you're putting up 200
million dollars to put it on 4 000
screens you're gonna tend to go for the
tried and true and i think that's really
what they've done and it's really hurt
the new writer it's really hurt the
person that has honed their craft and
has written some great specs that are
just not getting looked at because there
isn't a home for it
so my my advice is don't be angry
it hurts me when i see writers who are
not working blasting the things that are
getting made it seems the writers do
that more than anything and and i
understand the frustration i'm not
saying you're wrong to feel that way
but i don't think you're doing anything
good for yourself
by
by blasting what's getting made go make
something better or just go make
something and show the world what you
can do
don't don't talk about it be about it
you know that's that's the advice i give
to people that that have aspirations
again i keep repeating myself it's not
coming to you you have to go on out and
get it and whether that's go work on a
set you know a day or two a week for
free
um or it's going out and getting a dslr
and a couple of people from a local
acting class and playing out scenes and
really doing a poc a proof of concept on
your vision of what your script can be
that's how that's how it's going to get
done for you
you know that's that's my advice and
that's my feeling on it i think
hollywood has gotten quite lazy i think
they've gotten complacent i think they
are
content with the numbers that they get
with their
remakes of the same old same old i'm not
i'm not
endorsing it at all that's why i go out
in the dirt and do what i do i i don't
personally like that stuff at all i
understand the anger and the frustration
but
being angry about it and and trying to
get attention online or trying to pull
down other people that are doing stuff
that you're not doing doesn't it doesn't
help anybody just go show them what you
can do sure
i would enjoy seeing a remake of alice
or taxi oh taxi i don't know striking a
car that's one of my favorites i don't
mean you know
would people would be uber you just call
it uber that's true or lyft or yeah just
call it lyft or uber um alice would be
great one of my favorite shows growing
up with linda lavin and uh victory back
and yeah yeah that was a great show for
those of you who don't know what it is
look at some great television um all in
the family can never be made again we
know that
um but there were some great shows that
they haven't remade
but they they do they do find a way to
keep remaking and rebranding stuff and
that's all about built-in branding
well two broke girls was similar
to alice in some ways but i realized it
was much you know
raunchier and
right you know push some boundaries it
did yeah i don't think it get made today
oh you don't think so i don't know i
didn't watch the show but i've heard
that that
in some of the discussions that i've had
with some of the writers that we do um
on some of the platforms that we
interact with you know aspiring
screenwriters and they want to pitch and
they talk about different things and
somebody was talking about two broke
girls i've never seen an episode of it
and
somebody had said do you think that that
would get made today and a lot of people
said no they pushed some boundaries so
i just that's one that's kind of like
you know we obviously know
blazing saddles is the go-to that would
never get made today
and you know you think about the content
in that film
um
but forgive me two year old girls was
like less than ten years ago right i
think it was yeah so so we've
we've changed that much where we can't
in that short of time we we it would be
too much to push
again i haven't seen it i just found it
interesting that you know it's funny
whether it's an industry conversation or
it's just people
the joke is always like well you know
blazing saddles would never get made
today
that's like the go-to for film and and
it was just kind of weird that everybody
was kind of on this two broke girls
bandwagon i could be wrong i've been
wrong you know 100 times today but
i i just found that odd that people
thought so i thought it was a very
successful sitcom that
looked endearing and fun and you know
i'm afraid i'm a fan of whitney i just
never got into the show
but it just seemed to strike a chord
with a few people on these on these
different you know webinars we were
doing and they all seem kind of like
yeah do you think that would get made
today did they push them maybe it was
racial or sexual boundaries since me too
since some of the other things we've
been through as a society did they push
those envelopes you would know you've
seen it
i haven't seen that many episodes but i
know from the few that i did yes there
was definitely content
on there i think that's probably what's
not in it which probably made the show
which probably made the show good
you know we have we have
we went through a time i'm probably
going to really ruffle some feathers
with this one so let's let's do it
we went through a time as a society we
got so desensitized
you know when natural-born killers came
out the big fear was oh my god have we
gotten to that point in society where
things are said and done and we don't
even blink at it anymore we don't care
we're okay with that
and then
now we've gotten to a point where
we really
really are trying not to offend certain
people or push boundaries anymore and i
think it's really interesting how
50 when did when did natural born
killers come out you know 25 years ago
how that really turned it into how
desensitized we've become
to now how sensitive we are
think about that i mean it's been a
radical shift
especially in the last four years
well it seems like with cinema and
television but then everyone's okay
pulling out cameras if an incident
happens in real life
so it's like
it's okay for us to do that
and share some horrific things that way
and that's acceptable well it's real
life that's what's happening
okay so then we don't want to see it in
the cinema even though this is what's
being apparently known okay but i always
thought already imitated live so
okay you know i'm not disagreeing with
you
i just but i see the difference yeah you
know i knew the gentleman who put the
rodney king beating on the air
that was a much longer tape than we saw
as a public
um i think he acquired the tape for 300
from the gentleman who you know got the
camcorder and was filming outside his
balcony
and um it was very disturbing there's
nothing good about it i'm not making
light of what we didn't see but there
was a lot that wasn't shared with the
public
and that changed everything so it really
when that rodney king incident hit the
airwaves as a society we we woke up to a
whole different animal in our in our you
know the underbelly of what was going on
and
i i it's you know obviously what we went
through
you know with george floyd in the last
year you know and that being caught on
camera
and and it's just it's
you know
you're right i mean
the things that are shown that people
are catching on live camera are just
there's no we didn't think twice about
it it's shocking sometimes sure i don't
know if you know again we become
desensitized to a lot of things we see
but
do we want it in the art that we go pay
to see
and is is us as storytellers i think
there are some filmmakers and i and i
mean this with
the purists of heart please understand
where this is coming from i think there
are some storytellers that have a a
right
and should be given
the past
to show and exploit certain things in
their art
because i think there is so much that we
see
on a on a camera that's caught in 30
seconds
where so often
when when the right artist tells that
story they get into
the build up they they get into the
aftermath you know we we are so used to
seeing news
like that we'll look at you know
somebody have a fit and a walmart
because they're not wearing a mask we'll
see somebody get choked out by a police
officer
and it just comes at us at the speed of
light
and when somebody can take an hour and a
half two hours and really break down
the psyche and the build up and what
happened and then the aftermath you know
we don't have
when we see something shocking on the
news which is usually what you know news
is now 50 somebody's camera it feels
like
there's never a follow-up it's very rare
you know they may say oh there was there
was sadly there was somebody killed in a
street race they found the guy
but we don't get the aftermath that's a
good point and that's that's what i
don't like about the news is you know
obviously we did with george floyd and
some of the other situations that are
similar that we've been dealing with as
a society because it's it's warranted
that and it's it's it's attracted that
much attention and rightfully so but we
watch stuff all the time on on social
media that we just went through it and
we watched something crazy it goes on
for 20 seconds we whipped over and see
something else we never know the outcome
of that we don't know what caused it and
i think there are
some artists that are sensitive
enough they have a sensitivity and the
ability to really tell a story from
beginning to end in aftermath you know
beginning middle end and dominae
of what happened and i think too many of
us storytellers just feel what we're
storytellers we can do it and i think i
think there's a very very select few who
have the right to do it
you